the design evolved over time with metal
plow shares introduced to improve
durability and
efficiency the Chinese developed the
iron plow during the Han Dynasty further
enhancing agricultural
techniques in medieval Europe the heavy
plow transformed farming in Northern
regions with dense
soils today modern plows and tractors
equipped with advanced technology
continue to draw inspiration from these
ancient designs ensuring food security
and supporting agricultural economies
worldwide number five the
compass the compass invented in ancient
China during the Han Dynasty 206 BC 220
ad transformed navigation and
exploration